cette route a été extrêmement difficile
et malgré tout aujourd'hui vous formez
cette merveilleuse famille qu'est-ce qui
trotte dans la tête les paroles de petit
Bryan il m'a dit papa
quand tu as peur de rien
moi aussi
j'ai peur de perdre quelqu'un que j'aime
Dominique Toretto tu vas savoir ce
qu'elle a peur la vraie
tu t'es construit une vie de rêve avec
l'amour de ta famille
moi j'ai pas eu cette chance
tu m'as tout volé
mon avenir
ma famille
cette fois
à mon tour de prendre les tiens
un par un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il vient vous chercher avec tout son
arsenal
je sais plus
l'un de nous pourrait ne pas revenir
mais on doit se battre
de jamais accepter la mort quand la
douleur est due
[Musique]
c'est un piège
il essaie de nous séparer
parce qu'on voulait gagner beaucoup et
pour le respect
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je cours pour éviter un bain
de sang
[Musique]
c'est ça le problème d'avoir une famille
nombreuse
lesquelles d'entre eux qui va choisir de
sauver
c'est parti
et tout le monde
[Musique]
tu sais toujours conduire
à ton avis
[Musique]
je suis là
ils arrivent tu pourras jamais me
prendre ma famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coucou ma belle on émerge je le crois
pas c'est une blague
[Musique]